how bad you ask
well
according to new reports
the new evidence that the january 6
committee has received
mostly of course through this alex
holder documentary footage
is so intense and so overwhelming
that they have now decided to postpone
the remainder of their televised hearing
so that they can digest
all of this new
information
all of this new evidence they're calling
it evidence
not just information
this is evidence folks
the use of that word of course legally
speaking
implies that there is something there
something there that the committee needs
something there that the committee can
use
to possibly go after more leads go after
more people call more witnesses
find new paths which to investigate
they're not postponing these hearings
lightly either
they didn't just look at it and say okay
yeah you're going to push all this back
no no they understand how powerful these
hearings have been
right they know that the public is
watching them they know that it is
affecting public opinion donald trump's
unfavorability ratings have gone up
since these hearings began
more people say that yes he was involved
yes he should be criminally charged
that poll has basically flipped
since
these hearings began
so by postponing them
the committee has taken a big risk but
they believe the risk will be worth the
reward
and that of course is based on the
information they have seen thus far
from that documentary footage
so it's got to be something good it's
got to be more than just ivanka
contradicting herself possibly lying
under oath to the committee
there's got to be much more than that
for them to push these hearings back
couple days couple weeks we don't even
really know yet
but when they come back
they're going to show us what's in this
footage
and i'm expecting some pretty big
fireworks
we have to take a quick break again i am
farron cousins you can find me on
youtube at youtube.com slash the ring of
fire and youtube.com fair and balanced
and i'm across all social media twitter
instagram and facebook at farron
balanced this is the david pakman show
and we'll be right back